who
are the taliban what do they stand for
what do they want
obviously year by year this changes so
what is the nature
of this organization can they be a
legitimate peaceful kind respectful
uh government
sort of holder of power or
or are they fundamentally
not capable of doing so yeah
i mean the briefest answer would be that
they are a
clerical
slash
military organization
um
they have
this is kind of a
imperfect metaphor but
years ago a german scholar used the term
caravan to describe them and that that
has some attractive elements because
different people have joined the taliban
for different purposes at different
times but today
and people tell us you know scholars who
know more about the room than i have
said listen
the taliban is this kind of hodgepodge
of different actors and people and
competing interests
and i think
so we have a lot of scholars say listen
they're it's polycentric
it's got people in
this city in that city and so on i think
actually
i was very skeptical how do they know
this i mean this is an organization that
doesn't
want you to know
where their money comes from and so on
but i would say
now that we have a clearer picture of
what has happened
i'd say they are a astoundingly
well-organized
clerical military organization
that has a
very cohesive
and enduring ideology
which is quite idiosyncratic if we zoom
out and continue the conversation we're
having about islam and how we think
about radicalism and
you know who's drawn to what um
people throw different terms
around to describe the taliban
some use a term
that links it to
a kind of school of thought born in the
19th century in india the deobandi
school
but if you look at their teachings
it's very clear now i think that
these labels it's like saying you know
you're an mit guy well what does that
mean i mean mit is home to
dozens of different potentially
kinds of intellectual orientations right
i mean attaching the name of the school
doesn't quite capture
i mean you're interested in it it's
complicated i mean actually mit is
interesting because
i would say mit is different than
stanford for example yeah i think mit
has a more kind of narrow
yeah um bad analogy in my part maybe
well no it's interesting because i would
argue that there's some aspect of a
brand like taliban or mit yeah no
relation
that
has a kind of uh interact like
the the brand results in the behavior of
the like enforces a kind of behavior on
the people and the people feed the brand
and like there's a loot i think yeah
stanford is a good example of something
that's more distributed there's
sufficient amount of diversity
in like all kinds of like centers and
all that kind of stuff that the the
the the brand doesn't become one thing
yeah mit is so engineering it's yeah i
think than that okay
scratching my teeth scratching for two
because i think stanford's more like mit
than than
than you might imagine but uh but isn't
talbot isn't it pretty
i don't think there's a diversity so
yeah sorry so just a rephrase so so
people say oh the deobandi school i'm
like what is that i mean but the taliban
are
they're an ethnic movement
they represent
a vision of
pashtun power right questions are people
who
are quite internally diverse
who
actually
speak multiple dialects of pashto who
reside across the frontier of pakistan
and afghanistan
there are pashtuns who live all over the
planet right there's a community in
moscow california everywhere right so
it's a global diaspora of sorts
pashtuns have a kind of genealogical
imagination so that lots of pashtuns can
tell you the names of their grandparents
great grandparents and so on and that's
kind of a there's a sense of pride in
that
posture language is a kind of
core element of that identity but it's
not universal so for example
you can meet people who say i am pashtun
but i don't know pashto
so as you as you claw away at this idea
it's amorphous it also means different
things different people different times
so
saying the taliban
our costume requires lots of qualifiers
because
lots of passions will say no no i i have
nothing to tell bond i hate those people
you know so
the taliban tried to mobilize other posh
students with limited success
but their core membership is almost
exclusively pashtun and they say
no no we represent afghans we represent
pious muslims and so in recent
two three years
they've gone further to say no we have
other other groups we have uzbeks we
have tajiks we have hazaras
and in the north of afghanistan in
recent years they did do a bit better
at drawing in people who were very
dispected because of the government
and they were able to diversify their
ranks somewhat but if you watch august
15 and who they've appointed
what language they've used how they've
presented themselves it's clear that
you know they are poshtune they are male
and they
are extremely ideologically
cohesive
and
disciplined i'd say right so i think
that a lot of the polycentrism blah blah
some of that stuff was the way to fight
a war
um they are they are fundamentally you
know a guerrilla movement
they see themselves as kind of
pious robin hoods
the rhetoric is very much about taking
from the rich taking the privilege
giving to the poor
being on the side of the underdog
fighting against evil
and so i mean their their bag if you
like their thing their their central
theme their brand is about public
morality and so their origin story going
about 1994 is that
they interceded they broke up a gang of
criminals
who were trying to rape people
and so there's a branching kind of like
emphasis on like sexuality and on on
public morality
and really being the core of like you
know we're gonna restore order and
impulse morality
and how that translates into governance
is something they've never sorted out i
mean how do you run a banking system if
your intellectual priorities are really
about you know the length of a beard
and then and then their path to power
in a kind of abstract sense i mean a lot
of that was very much driven by um
if you like
propagating the problems of martyrdom
and that sounds i don't mean to say that
in a way that
to make it sound ridiculous makes sound
like it's um
you know a moral judgment it's simply i
think a fact it's a fact of their appeal
that
they promised young men
who have known
nothing else but
studying in certain schools if at all
but they've known fighting and they've
known they've known victimization
and this isn't i'm not asking for like
sympathy for them but i think the
reality is that a lot of
we know about the kind of foot soldiers
is that they
they lost families and bombings um
in airstrikes in night raids
you know
i mean orphans have always been a stream
living in in all male society
not knowing girls not knowing women
hearing things from outside about places
like kabul and so there's always been
this kind of urban rural dimension it's
not it's not just that but
i think there's a
there's a whole imagination
that being taliban
captures
you